l'évolution du tour de taille est
associé depuis plusieurs années par le
milieu scientifique un risque de
maladies cardiovasculaires et de diabète
selon une recherche menée par l'institut
national de santé publique du québec
deux fois plus d'adultes qu'il ya 20 ans
soit 2 3 millions de québécois sont
atteints d'obésité abdominale
pour la première fois le tour de taille
des québécois a doublé en 20 ans c'est
40 % de la population adulte québécois
sans remarque aussi c'est que ya environ
1 adulte sur cinq qui considérés comme
ayant un poids santé qui a quand même un
tour de taille qui est élevé et qui le
place un risque élevé de développer
plusieurs maladies chroniques
par ailleurs une femme sur deux contre
un homme sur trois qui souffrent
d'obésité abdominale sont à risque de
développer des problèmes de santé
ce qui me préoccupe le plus c'est la
progression du tour de taille chez les
jeunes adultes québécois dans notre
étude
on a retrouvé des données de l'année
1981 et ont remarqué qu' il y avait
environ 2 % des gens qui avaient une
circonférence d'attaqués placées à un
risque élevé maintenant c'est un jeune
sur cinq cellules jab double immo sim le
jeu comme un revenu plus à la normale ne
me joue à la différence si jusque-là
marche fait d'exercer
mais ça a changé ma vie j'ai tellement
de mal bouffe thurman monde qui marque
la malle bourse que c'est un peu normal
qu'elle selon le chercheur la mauvaise
qualité de l'offre alimentaire et la
sédentarité sont responsables de la
progression du tour de taille dont les
données se compare avec le reste du
canada et de l'occident ici nicole jamet
radio canada québec